did hey youtubers it's Charlie! this is
going to be my
Doctor Who Christmas special video
hopefully you've had a chance to see it
definitely a lot of fun not quite what I
expected but it was really fun
Nick Frost totally killed it as Santa
Claus and everyone really wants to talk
about the ending is was
you know the one big twist in the middle
so we'll get to that
saucer with top five moments and then
I'll do East rake the my review
and a new enter the giveaway starts
right now all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video
real simple and I just took you a
tomorrow announce the winner so
tangerines in medicare to go and
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the episode yet 30 with top five
moments
number five stance that meets car for
the first time
I guess we should say dream Santa Claus
meet car for the first time
she seemed surprised to see him so if
she saw Santa Claus in her dreams as a
child
he look different I to let Nick Frost
but I haven't seen
a lot of his a dust-up soap my
mind mostly went to that place whenever
I was watching him kinda stumbled over
his words trying to pretend like he was
not santa claus
I'm sure some were a guy right in them
and paper lapping their butts off
the elves if you didn't recognize them
dan starkey obviously place tracks just
looks cool we're without his tracks
makeup on
make the memo line is actually from
misfits that's where most people prior
recognize him from
I was glad later in the episode that
they did call back to this moment
car meeting on the rooftop for the first
time number four Fe Marseille
dances the dream grab the way for the
first time this is like our first intro
to the dream crabs
and we don't really get a lot a context
but does the fact that she starts
dancing to the Christmas music which is
so hilarious
it isn't that the appropriate weirdness
for a Doctor Who Christmas special
episode
if it's something that Matt Smith would
do to start dancing wildly
if he didn't recognize her I mean at
least I think up a Marseille is mostly
be from the White Queen but she has that
some other stuff too
231 my favorite characters in a
Christmas special just in general like
to guest stars
really felt like they were teasing her
as a potential new companion
so I will truly add her to my list that
people I'd like to see become campaign
series 9
Famer save for the next Doctor Who
companion his lands rate in at like
perfect territory where she's
super quick to the super quick wit she's
bunny in it looks like she's all start
for denture
given that she's a game of Thrones band
don't you just wonder why she didn't
conjure
like tearing into
Jamie Lannister someone else from West
rose saber I mean is the Doctor Who
specials I didn't expect any game
Thrones jokes
so I was actually really happy when I
saw that on our paper at the end if you
really want to put your tinfoil
the rehab on her saying I'm scared in
the doctor applying
good that means you're not an idiot is
the best sign
did he think someone has companion
potential get the doctor is
suddenly evaluating people like everyone
he meets sizing them up
I think that would be a big plus if
you're in the market for new companion
especially at the end when she wants to
exchange numbers with everyone
it is reminded me of the girl in the
shop and I do believe I think her
character actually said she didn't work
in a shop
I can remember what I pet shop it was
though just so meek went to dances but
if
we're talking like ensure like terms:
there's no such thing as coincidence is
the universe israelis ole the number
three Michael Tran really likes release
got
for those that don't know Michael Tran
is the younger son
%uh the second doctor yet she has an
older brother they both done a lot of
Doctor Who stuff
previously michael has been in a big
finish story a second doctor Big Finish
story called the Lord's the red planet
it's really his older brother David it's
been a lot a doctor who
he was in midnight during series 4 using
a lot a classic episodes as a child with
his father
when Patrick Troughton was still playing
the second doctor on TV
he's played billions in a couple big
finish stories and he was one of the
dollar operators during the five ish
doctors reboot during the fiftieth
anniversary last year
in real life I think they've also
starred with something the other doctors
former doctors that is in outside
production stuff that isn't Doctor Who
just explain the alien joked that he
made though to the doctor
which i think is totally rinse the
doctor's never heard a release got
apparently is not a fan
although I do think that he has seen
films but he understands what movies are
but they call that alien literally I me
cuz the base others
but else aside dream warriors from Mr
announced read every got sucked into the
TV
then you have John Carpenter's The Thing
with aliens being dug out on the ice
and then you had the inception angle but
their dreams within dreams
especially with that and a moment to
with the tangerine but like the little
top spinning at the end of Inception
when my favorite things about doctor who
is that is not afraid to get super metal
like this than
do these kinds of jokes you do what they
do whenever they're conceiving episodes
is that they have their story line and
then after the
forget to the story is done like hey
let's kinda make this look like dream
warriors are poor guys were someone gets
sucked into the TV
been intentionally write it to be like
some other movie you those references
read it after the fact
I like the idea that moffett wrote the
special and then after the fact was like
you know this can looks like John
Carpenter's The Thing
are maybe the Alien movie number two
Deeping cameo
this it ahead a time that they be
referencing the event to the finale
sup Danny pete was at least going to be
mentioned I was a little surprised to
see 'em
but the minute car went into the dream I
felt like we all
probably knew yet reply concede any pain
here I like that they paid off the
blackboards to
by birds were such a big deal during
series 8 they didn't I'll explain I mean
it's is
as far as we know the doctor likes to
write things down in the episode
you trying to tell apart something
through her subconscious but maybe
during series 8 when he wrote on others
blackboards and wasn't sure who wrote
those things down
he was trying to tell himself something
subconsciously I think that mostly
dovetailed with the master coming back
like you turn it on top about that but
it's possible that it could mean
something else
but it's been honest about the fact that
series 8 is both compound is run in
general
isn't quite as planned out is Matt Smith
run but whatever Matt Smith started his
run
he had a pretty good idea of where
trends or was going
is it now though he only has a few ideas
about the twisties and have a completely
worked out
because I think they're not really sure
when cabal is gonna leave he has signed
on thru series 10
but remains to be seen whether now he's
gonna make it as long as Matt Smith the
David Tennant
similar Anderson was told a great they
played a little fast and loose with the
logic
really it's Kara talking to herself even
though the doctors in there are also
talking to our
by the way this your dreams love by the
players in the logic
there's two ways to think about it the
dream crabs are like the holiday
like they set the stage and your mind
fills in the gaps but he creates
everything
or you can look at some of the
characters is being created by the dream
crabs
I think it's the first one I think that
the dream crabs just create the holiday
and you are completely responsible for
filling it out with the scenario
that's why they can conjure sent that to
defend themselves as a defense mechanism
guinea pig is also penned in that same
debate any was even wearing a Santa
costume
in a doctor even called her out on it
you know that this is big so I think
that she conjured any pain as a way to
see him again
and as a defense mechanism just for
those that are asking yes I do think the
denny pincus told that there isn't some
crazy twist is going to be some
inception middle finger from Moffitt
saying that
it was all a dream the tangerine at the
end did kinda make you wonder that
but no I don't think it's gonna be that
crazy I think he is still dead
gaping still dead there was with the
whole last Christmas theme was about
their very last Christmas are the bonus
Christmas
like anything called it in whenever one
moment Doctor Who
inception you can look at the dreams
within dreams twist a couple different
ways
one it's a little bit of a middle finger
saying that all you know now that israel
has been all this time invested in this
storyline
haha and get too upset by stuff like
that me know the I think it's okay
I'd be more pissed off that they did
that in the finale where there are like
this whole season has been a dream
that our people crap the whole idea the
shared dream are shared nightmare
as the doctor eventually call that would
overturn it a poltergeist people at 38
sucked into the TV
because all the way back to listen you
know with little boy Danny pink
in the doctor had a crazy idea you know
what if we all have the same nightmare
everyone in the universe all at some
point in their lives but the idea of a
shared dream
and other a lot of questions about Santa
may BBB not being a Time Lord
I don't think that he is but the fact
that there was a tangerine at the end
and I do think they're awake all those
kinda meant to be that big question mark
you know are they dreaming are they not
dreaming I think he's an alien like
the doctor who has some metaphysical
properties although I do like the idea
of the
root of clicker like the beeper lucky
close in like a card or
it does make you wonder if he has time
or technology and in a lot of people
were huge fans a bit but the whole
real not real you know is the doctor
fictitious is the real percent goes back
to rebut a Sherwood with
Robin Hood is Robin Hood real is not
real do the doctors adventures
have to be real to influence people
words the fact that they have on people
the only thing that matters
really to me that feels like the big
hand wave you know don't worry too much
about this
all that matters is that these Doctor
Who stories make you feel something
as the net in a lotta cartoons this year
don't overanalyze things don't let the
truth get in the way of a good story
several months while I do just by myself
getting swept up in stories and having
fun
just one more big moffett fairy tale let
me know that what was your favorite
moment from the episode and he's made a
question for you guys
would you guys wanna see p Marseille she
played shown up would you wanna see her
become the next companion
just an update on series 9 so yes car as
seen in the episode when they announced
that
she's coming back for series 9
supposedly should be leaving after the
first couple episodes
may be as late as halfway through the
series as bars we note that
the plan right now that can always
change you can do is change your mind is
down for the entire series
early sooner they're still planning that
out they've only play in the first
couple episodes even though Moffitt has
an idea for
what he wants the twist to be in the
finale use talking about it in the
latest issue of Doctor Who Magazine is
that
have an idea for what the big twist is
going to be the end a series 9
but it's not as planned out is trends or
whatever Matt Smith start in the
eleventh hour
so here's the couple the East raise that
I have been already mentioned when my
paper ones when the reading the first
word
out on the books Kara has the mall open
it to Page 12
the words are very very very good
it's like a valium of Energy's patting
themselves on the back it's a little bit
I don't think that they were trying to
make a direct reference to it but I do
think that would compel the
minutemen over the doctor was explaining
the brain freeze it was a little there
will be blood
like I take your milkshake your brain
milkshake and drink it up
that's all I could think about I take
your brain milkshake Nick Frost had a
lot to digest the doctor
mostly calling him out as potentially
fictitious to but the dreamy we need is
a nice spin on tiny why mean
I'm really hoping it doesn't catch on
though another big been a dreamy we need
as we learn series 9 episode 1 can be
called the magician's apprentice
there's actually a line that shown a
hand whenever she was scolding the
doctor
that's not very nice for someone who
looks like a magician they really are
leaning into the magician joke I totally
appreciate that
and the really big one was it looked
like that doctor
whenever he woke up from his dream crap
with inside the volcano from the finale
which implies he could have gone back
there he could have been somewhere else
like it could not been the buckingham
is looks like the same said that
actually had me worried I was like palm
and
please don't let the finale be a dream
so if you sign your Easter eggs that I
didn't mention just buy them below in
the comments
generally you know is lava overall I
give the episode
a solid a whose great as a Christmas
episode very self-contained
was still having a lot of references and
some other events during the regular
series
I was good
his points to stories when you don't you
have to completely understand everything
cuz I always try to get new people in
the Doctor Who
it's really hard to do that when the
story depends on other episodes
is that you can watch this without
understanding who Danny pink is
either just known that you someone who
had passed the wait was very precious to
cora
the pally felt very on character like
me. uses the still the same standoffish
doctor
who are you people sorry I reach you
very mind policy very sure lucky
and a lot of people have opinions about
car a deep knowledge in a coma did a
good job in this episode
I'm interested to see what they do with
her character like if they decide to
pursue the doctor clark more are doctor
oswald everyone I think about her
and like to see them take a break from
that so I was kinda glad when she didn't
go out doctor in this episode
it did seem like she was unusually
scared to the drink rad
about the screaming was a little much I
mean if she could take on the cyber men
if you could lie to their face
to save herself why was she so scared
the green crabs she went from like
cold-blooded killer
in the span of a couple months or
however long it's been since the miss
the finale in the time line
to like scared girl again they did imply
that you can start moving on
so it seems like she's going to be a
little more positive in future episodes
which i think is great because car being
depressed is no binders no room for
being depressed on the tartars
we have of time and space you're not
allowed to be depressed
all the guest actors were great Michael
tried it was so much fun thing him
famously with prime my favorite though
did because I feel like she has so much
companion potential
in for those rescue I feel like mop it
doesn't know who the next campaign is
going to be
if your gonna shoot the first episode
related he prolly has
at least the list up 34 people that they
winner down to
if they haven't picked someone they're
really close to picking someone
then out simulators and casting pretty
early in the process maybe they're
filming
series 8 so it's possible we could find
a panic February or March
to the new campaigns going to be and i
really am hoping that we see the new
campaign in the Premier
at least in a cameo so just a couple
quick updates on what's happening this
week's things are slowly getting back to
normal
the be shooting the Charlotte Christian
special before the first episode series
neither
I will be doing some beers for sure like
in the next couple days I'm also working
on a Q&A for tomorrow
so be sure to leap all your questions
and if you guys want me to do live
me and my question let me know I take
early tonight which and the description
my next Doctor Who bonus video is
probably going to be just breaking
all my favorite part
and specials just now that we have a new
ended up going to put them on context
again
so if you do have a big favor Christmas
special let me know in the comments to
right now if you're on your mobile phone
or a tablet you can actually click here
for new mobile Inc the mobile links
it seems the links over here so click
here for that you need I'll be posting
tomorrow
any quick cure for all my other
documents videos thank you so much for
watching
so everybody happy holidays it was the
time into a vacation albeit one
but the high five I'll see you tonight